Die Schweiz -
ein Land, in dem man gerne lebt.
Ein Land,
in dem eigentlich alles funktioniert.
Prochain arrêt: Lausanne.
Bonjour.
Viele Menschen
tragen im Hintergrund dazu bei.
Kurt Fischer
fegt Kamine im Mittelland.
Valentina Andrej
produziert Bio-Wein im Wallis.
Alex Beauval steuert Dampfschiffe
über den Genfersee.
Und Beryl Jost
betreut Kinder in einem Zürcher Hort.
Wie leben diese Menschen?
Wofür setzen sie sich ein?
Und was beschäftigt sie?
Vier Menschen und ihr Alltag.
Ein Tag im Leben der Schweiz.
5 Uhr morgens im Kanton Aargau.
Kaminfegermeister Kurt
ist eigentlich kein Morgenmuffel.
Saillon im Kanton Wallis,
1 Std. später.
Winzerin Valentina
wird den Tag draussen verbringen.
Erst mal einen Kaffee.
Dann schaue ich auf das Wetter.
Sie sagen Regen voraus
mit ein bisschen Sonne.
Kurt ist immer
der Erste in der Werkstatt.
Früh am Morgen kann sich der Aargauer
ganz ungestört
seinem Morgenritual widmen.
Ich machte früher Kunstturnen.
Bewegung war immer
etwas sehr, sehr Wichtiges.
Du fühlst dich einfach
irgendwie besser,
wenn du schon etwas getan hast.
7 Uhr in Montherod
zwischen Lausanne und Genf.
Schiffskapitän Alex ist Franzose,
lebt jedoch mit seiner Frau
und seinem Sohn in der Schweiz.
Ça se dégage.
Am Morgen ist es immer eng
für die ganze Familie.
Es ist ein kleines Rennen -
buchstäblich
und im übertragenen Sinne.
Und da ich heute Morgen
joggen werde,
stehe ich ein wenig früher auf.
In Rupperswil
instruiert Kurt seine Belegschaft.
Er ist von der Gemeinde gewählt
und für die ganze Region zuständig.
Ich lasse dir die Brandschutzsachen
zur Bearbeitung hier.
Das ist ein Doppeleinfamilienhaus.
Eines wird abgerissen.
Kurt beschäftigt
fünf Männer und vier Frauen.
Zwei davon als Lehrlinge.
Vor 21 Jahren hat sich der 53-Jährige
selbstständig gemacht.
Kommen alle raus?
Es ist schon cool.
Angefangen haben wir zu zweit.
Mittlerweile furzt hier
einer nach dem anderen ins Tal.
Das ist schon schön, schon witzig.
Zur gleichen Zeit im Wallis:
Winzerin Valentina
bewohnt in ihrem grossen Weinkeller
eine kleine Zweizimmerwohnung.
Das Haus ist alt: Zuerst hatte ich
Angst, weil es so viele Türen hat,
den Keller unten, auf
der anderen Seite noch zwei Keller.
Es ist sehr gross,
aber ich habe mich daran gewöhnt.
Sie arbeitet v.a. alleine
und stellt je nach Saison
Arbeitskräfte tageweise an.
Heute muss sie
eine Mitarbeiterin in Riddes abholen.
Im Moment ist es etwas ruhiger.
Die Reben liegen zwei bis drei
Wochen hinter dem Vorjahr zurück.
Es ist ein spätes Jahr.
Wir haben den Schnitt beendet,
wir haben die Triebe gesäubert.
Jetzt kümmern wir uns
ein wenig um den Boden.
Voilà.
On va attendre ici qu'ils arrivent.
Bonjour, Maria. Ça va?
* Das Auto springt nicht an. *
Das hat er mir noch nie angetan.
Ich verstehe nichts davon.
Ich frage Antonio,
ob er ein Überbrückungskabel hat.
In Montherod im Kanton Waadt
ist es 6.45 Uhr.
Alex ist in zweiter Ehe
mit Silvie verheiratet.
Die gebürtige Walliserin
arbeitet 80 % im Personalwesen.
Die beiden
teilen sich die Familienarbeit auf.
Fürs Wecken ist Alex zuständig.
Martin ist sein grosses Glück.
Unter der Scheidung von seiner
ersten Frau hat Alex sehr gelitten.
Seine 15-jährige Tochter
sieht er nur alle zwei Wochen.
Sie ist mit ihrer Mutter
in Frankreich geblieben.
Trink vorsichtig! Uh là là!
Mais non, tu as déjà fini?
Ça, c'est avalé.
Bisou.
Während Silvie
Martin zu ihren Eltern bringt,
macht sich Alex fürs Joggen bereit.
Ich fahre bis Nyon
und laufe dann nach Genf.
Das sind ungefähr 20 km.
Es ist 7.30 Uhr.
Um diese Zeit sind
die meisten Menschen in der Schweiz
schon an der Arbeit.
In Stäfa am Zürichsee lebt Beryl
mit ihrem Partner zusammen.
* Vibrieren eines Handys *
Sie ist Sozialpädagogin
und Hortleiterin
und muss erst um 10 Uhr
in Zürich sein.
Ich habe noch jeden Tag
einen Zettel von meinem Schatz.
* Sie lacht. *
Das ist eigentlich seit sieben
Jahren so: Entweder ich oder er,
wer früher aufsteht,
hinterlässt eine Spur, genau.
Sie kann sich Zeit lassen und macht
jeden Morgen 10 Min. Meditation.
Ich bin eigentlich
nicht so ruhig am Morgen.
Ich stehe auf,
der Kopf beginnt sofort zu denken
und spielt den ganzen Tag ab.
Deshalb ist es für mich
extrem wichtig,
etwas in die Langsamkeit
zurückzukommen.
Wenn ich das am Morgen tue,
gelingt es mir am Tag öfter,
auf dieses Gefühl zurückzukommen.
Valentina
steckt immer noch in Riddes fest.
Vielen Dank! Wir sind gerettet.
Männer sind einfach wunderbar.
Valentina, die gebürtige Rumänin,
kam aber nicht
wegen eines Mannes in die Schweiz,
sondern um Französisch zu lernen.
Sie war damals 20 und
hat sich sofort ins Wallis verliebt.
Ich liebe die Berge,
die Bäume und die Natur.
Materielles bedeutet mir nicht viel,
schöne Häuser und so,
das sagt mir nichts.
Ich liebe die Natur.
Es fühlt sich einfach gut an.
Es gibt mir Energie,
wenn ich diese Berge sehe,
wenn ich schöne Blumen sehe,
dann spüre ich etwas.
8.30 Uhr am Genfersee.
Seit zehn Jahren
trainiert Alex fünfmal in der Woche
und nimmt regelmässig
an Bergmarathons teil.
Gerade trainiert er
für einen Trial in Spanien.
Ja, ich brauche das.
Ich hoffe, es hält an.
Die Jahre vergehen.
Alex liebt die Ruhe
und ist gerne allein.
Mit meiner Arbeit
ist es sehr schwierig,
eine Teamsportart oder eine
mit genauen Zeitplänen zu betreiben.
Daher passt dieser Sport wirklich
gut zu mir und meiner Arbeit.
Normalerweise
braucht er ungefähr 2 Std.
für die 20 km von Nyon nach Genf.
In Rupperswil im Kanton Aargau
ist Kurt heute
mit seiner Stiftin Marisa unterwegs.
Du kannst einfach klingeln.
Gemeinsam müssen sie
ein grosses Bauernhaus reinigen,
und Marisa muss
für die Abschlussprüfung üben.
Warum ist Kurt eigentlich
Kaminfeger geworden?
Da ist unser alter Kaminfegermeister
schuld,
den wir in Möriken hatten,
wo ich aufgewachsen bin.
Der war einfach
ein zufriedener Mensch,
der wusste immer einen Spruch,
war immer gut gelaunt.
Und ich hatte das Gefühl:
Das ist cool, das will ich auch.
Das war etwa
in der dritten Primarklasse,
als ich entschieden habe:
Ich werde Kaminfeger.
Ich habe es voll durchgezogen,
unglaublich.
Marisa, du kannst starten.
Das ist unser Telefon.
Unten kontrolliert er, was sie macht.
Das mache ich natürlich,
flott wie ich bin.
In zwei Monaten
hat Marisa ihre Abschlussprüfungen.
Die Leute
sind immer wieder überrascht:
"Ah, Frauen machen das auch?"
Ja, sicher.
Ich merkte es auch in der Familie:
Als ich sagte,
ich mache eine Lehre
als Kaminfegerin, sagten alle:
"Megacool,
das habe ich noch nie gehört."
"Man muss sie berühren, dann bringt
sie Glück." Und ich so: "Okay?"
Und jetzt bin ich hier,
und schon bald fertig mit der Lehre
und bin also
immer noch sehr glücklich.
Ja, siehst du?
Wenn du Ausbildner bist,
ist es einfach Hammer,
wenn du solches Feedback bekommst,
dann weisst du,
dass die Berufswahl
einfach gut herausgekommen ist.
Hammer, das Werkzeug,
das du ausgewählt hast.
Ich muss wirklich sagen:
Ich hatte grosse Freude.
In Genf am Schiffsteg.
Alex hat etwas mehr als 2 Std.
gebraucht. Kein neuer Rekord heute.
Gut, mit diesem Gegenwind, es war
ein bisschen ... Na ja, es ist gut.
Alex ist einer
von 120'000 Franzosen in der Schweiz.
Er arbeitet seit bald 30 Jahren bei
der Genfer Schifffahrtsgesellschaft.
Jetzt nehme ich
eine gemütliche Dusche,
nachher machen wir das Boot klar,
essen etwas,
und 15 Min. vor dem Einsteigen
ziehe ich die Uniform an
und mache nochmals
eine Tour ums Schiff.
Auf Schweizer Seen
fahren noch 17 Raddampfer.
Seit bald 14 Jahren
arbeitet Alex schon auf der Savoie.
Immer noch
mit der gleichen Begeisterung.
Ein Original,
ein gutes Instrument von 1914.
Seit einem Jahrhundert
benutzt man das gleiche Material.
In der Schweiz
verkehren viele Dampfschiffe.
Die Flotte
wird sogar wieder ausgebaut,
weil die Leute gerne Schiff fahren.
In Frankreich
ist es ein wenig anders:
Es gibt auch grosse Traditionen,
aber nicht diese.
Und es war nicht das,
was man mir hätte anbieten können,
als ich 20 war.
Ich wäre sicher
in Frankreich geblieben,
wenn ich diesen Job
dort hätte machen können.
Kurz vor 10 Uhr im Wallis.
Alors, on peut mettre les sacs ici,
Maria.
Valentina bewirtschaftet
seit fünf Jahren
verschiedene Rebberge
auf 4 ha rund um Saillon.
Sie hat sich zur Winzerin
und Weinhändlerin ausbilden lassen
und produziert biodynamischen Wein.
Heute sät sie Klee an.
So säst du von einer Seite.
Und dann machst du dasselbe
von der anderen Seite wieder zurück.
Ich habe den Klee gewählt,
weil er niedrig bleibt.
Ich versuche damit,
die Pflanzen zu unterdrücken,
die etwas zu hoch wachsen
und mit der Rebe konkurrieren.
Zudem wird der Boden so
mit Stickstoff angereichert.
Valentina ist immer noch beeindruckt
von der Schweizer Anbautradition
in steilem Gelände.
Hier haben wir vier Linien,
Mauer an Mauer.
Ich komme aus Rumänien, wir haben
Hektaren von verlassenen Weingärten.
Hier kultiviert man jeden Meter
Land, das finde ich unglaublich.
Mit 35 hat sie sich
als Bio-Weinproduzentin
bereits einen Namen gemacht.
Woher kommt
ihre Faszination für den Weinbau?
Von klein auf habe ich meinen Eltern
in der Landwirtschaft geholfen.
Die landwirtschaftlichen Grundsätze
bleiben die gleichen,
auch wenn es Tomaten sind.
Wir hatten auch einen Weinberg
in Rumänien.
Ich liebte es, Trauben zu pflücken.
Und als ich in Rumänien
meinen Abschluss machte,
ging ich in den Hängen
Trauben pflücken. Es war grossartig.
Da war eine Energie,
die hat Lust gemacht auf mehr,
die hat etwas ausgelöst.
Also: Du ziehst das raus.
Aber nicht zu fest zerren!
Nur an der Oberfläche.
Es ist kurz vor 10 Uhr am Zürichsee.
Beryl pendelt.
In einer halben Stunde
muss sie anfangen.
Vor dem Hort
hat sie in Jugendheimen gearbeitet.
Ich habe dort gemerkt,
dass ich nicht mehr rund um die Uhr,
an Wochenenden, an Abenden
und Nächten verfügbar sein wollte.
Dann bin ich als Stellvertretung
im Hort gelandet.
Dort, wo ich jetzt bin,
bin ich sozusagen stecken geblieben.
Ich fing dort auch
als Stellvertretung an und merkte:
Das Quartier gefällt mir sehr gut.
Und das Team hat sich
gerade neu zusammengestellt.
Das ist für mich bis heute
eine grosse Bereicherung.
Zudem liebt sie Kinder.
Beryl ist selbst als Tochter
von Schweizern in Uganda geboren
und hat immer wieder
im Ausland gelebt und gearbeitet.
Was schätzt sie besonders
in der Schweiz?
Was ich am meisten schätze,
ist die Freiheit,
jederzeit dorthin gehen zu können,
wo ich will.
Nicht eingesperrt zu sein,
keine Angst haben zu müssen,
sich einfach frei bewegen zu können.
Das ist etwas, das ich
sehr zu schätzen gelernt habe.
Auch durch andere Erfahrungen
beim Reisen.
Das finde ich extrem wichtig.
Hoi, Beryl!
- Hoi, Nicolina. Grüezi.
Hoi, Beryl.
- Hoi zusammen.
Seit neun Jahren
leitet sie einen Hort
im Zürcher Multikulti-Quartier
Kreis 4.
Neu haben in der Stadt Zürich
alle Kinder ein Recht
auf einen Betreuungsplatz
über Mittag.
Die Belegung
hat darum extrem zugenommen.
Im Schulhaus Hohl
gehen 320 Kinder zur Schule.
Zwei Drittel davon
werden im Moment noch
in sechs verschiedenen Horten
betreut.
Wir haben einen Hort,
der geschlossen werden wird
und dann integriert wird
in das Bestehende.
Wir werden vom Team her
neue Zusammensetzungen haben.
Das sind so die Veränderungen,
die vor der Tür stehen:
Was dann nachher der Einfluss
auf unseren Alltag ist,
wie wir das gestalten,
wie wir all die Kinder
über Mittag zum Essen bringen,
die wir dann haben werden,
wie wir die Abläufe gestalten,
ob wir noch Gruppenzeiten haben,
oder ob alles mehr in Bewegung ist.
Das sind viele Fragen,
die wir noch besprechen müssen.
Am Genfersee. Es ist 11 Uhr.
Bevor der Ansturm losgeht,
trifft sich Alex
mit seiner Crew zum Mittagessen.
Dieser Moment ist uns heilig.
Die Essenszeit mögen wir gerne.
Wir können uns ein bisschen
ausruhen, wir können zusammen essen.
Wir haben lange Tage,
und diesen kleinen Unterbruch finden
wir toll. Wir schätzen das sehr.
Sie haben keinen Stress.
Jeder weiss, was er zu tun hat.
Einige von uns
kennen sich seit vielen Jahren.
Die Älteren unter uns sind schon
lange hier, das funktioniert gut.
Kochvorbereitungen
laufen auch im Kanton Aargau.
Kurt hat den Mittagstisch eingeführt.
Jeder Mitarbeiter
hat eine Woche lang Küchendienst.
Bezahlte Arbeitszeit
selbstverständlich.
Der Mittagstisch ist eine
extrem gute Kommunikationsplattform.
Über Mittag sind sie in der Regel
bewaffnet mit Messer und Gabel,
niemand ist am Telefon
oder am Computer,
man kann auch persönlichere Sachen
miteinander besprechen.
Das ist ein wichtiger Beitrag, dass
in einem Team Arbeitswert herrscht.
Eine Arbeitsstelle soll Arbeitswert
haben und soll schön sein.
Der Chef nutzt die Zeit für
ein bisschen Unterricht mit Marisa.
Du,
wie hoch ist der Heizwert von Holz?
15'500 kJ/kg.
- Das ist super.
Das sind Sachen, die man mit
dem Kochen wunderbar verbinden kann.
Informationen weitergeben
oder auch Informationen rauskitzeln.
So z.B.: Du, Mare, wann kannst du
jetzt zur Autoprüfung?
Das verrate ich nicht.
* Kurt lacht. *
Das sagt sie nicht.
Im Schulhaus Hohl in Zürich
läutet es: Mittagspause.
Hallo, Lina.
Lina, was hast du noch vergessen?
Oh, Kärtchen.
Hoi, Nicolina. Hoi, Jean-Luc.
Heute kommen 32 zum Mittagessen.
Gesamthaft haben wir - ich muss
kurz nachschauen - 38 Anmeldungen,
aber die kommen natürlich
an verschiedenen Tagen.
Als wir anfingen,
hatten wir kein einziges
deutsch sprechendes Kind
in unserer Gruppe.
Dann fing es langsam an mit
den ersten Schweizern mit Kindern,
die ins Quartier gezogen sind.
Mittlerweile haben wir
etwa eine 50/50-Situation.
Und das finde ich
eigentlich sehr schön,
denn es profitieren alle
enorm gegenseitig voneinander.
Am Anfang macht Beryl
immer ein kleines Gruppengespräch.
Alle Sachen verstauen,
falls jemand noch etwas hat.
Die vierte Klasse
macht ja heute einen Ausflug.
Wohin geht ihr auf dem Ausflug,
Alexander?
Moschee.
- Eine Moschee besichtigen.
Wer von den Kindern,
die heute auf den Ausflug gehen,
war schon mal in einer Moschee?
Ich bete dort.
- Ja, genau.
Und wer von den Kindern, die
heute Nachmittag den Ausflug machen,
geht zum allerersten Mal
eine Moschee besichtigen?
Beryl muss die Zeit bis 12.45 Uhr
überbrücken.
Wegen der hohen Belegung müssen
die Kinder in zwei Etappen essen.
Mittagspause auch im Wallis.
Valentina geht mit Maria
ins Nouvo Burg in Saillon essen.
Das Restaurant
bezieht regelmässig Wein von ihr.
Valentina hatte keine Mühe,
sich hier im Wallis zu integrieren.
Ich glaube, es ist auch,
weil die Leute gesehen haben,
dass ich arbeite.
Als ich 2013/14 angefangen habe,
habe ich alles selbst gemacht,
den Anbau, die Lese.
Sie haben mir wohl geholfen,
weil sie gesehen haben,
dass ich alles mache.
Ich denke, das ist das, was zählt.
Essen ist fertig, auch in Rupperswil.
Am Mittagstisch mit dabei
ist auch immer Kurts Exfrau Rita.
Die beiden
haben das Geschäft gegründet
und zusammen eine 23-jährige Tochter.
Als Paar sind sie aber
schon lange getrennt.
Kurt, du hast gesagt,
du schiebst es in den Ofen.
Und ich habe ihn
einfach eingeschaltet.
Wenn du ein Kind hast, hast du eine
lebenslange Beziehung miteinander.
Das ist einfach so.
Wir konnten es einfach
so super lösen,
dass sie meine Chefsekretärin blieb,
und das funktioniert einfach super.
Beryl lässt die Kinder
am liebsten draussen rumtoben,
wenn sie aufs Essen warten müssen.
Hoppla!
Was gefällt ihr besonders
an ihrer Arbeit?
Jeder Tag ist anders.
Und auch das Frisch-ab-der-Leber,
man ist, wie man ist,
mit allen Gefühlen, die dazugehören,
das finde ich nach wie vor
einen schönen Teil.
Also, ihr drei!
Wir gehen noch mal nach hinten.
Endlich ist 12.45 Uhr.
Wir machen die Kärtchen.
Wir gehen hier entlang.
Heute gibt's noch
ein spezielles Geburtstagsritual.
Im Moment dürfen die Kinder
noch in Gruppen essen.
Beryl fände es wichtig,
dass das auch so bleibt.
Zurück in Genf.
Alex hat sich umgezogen.
Bonjour, Madame! Ça descend.
Messieurs dames, bonjour!
Bienvenus à bord.
Für die Menschen
ist die Uniform wichtig.
Bonjour, bienvenu à bord.
Sie hat Tradition, es wurde immer
eine strenge Uniform getragen.
Es liegt auch an uns,
diese Tradition zu pflegen.
Auch nach 30 Dienstjahren ist er
immer noch stolz auf sein Schiff.
* Schiffshorn *
Es ist ein Teil der Schweiz, die
Schiffe auf allen Seen der Schweiz,
das ist etwas Wichtiges.
Mit ihren Formen ...
Sie gehören einfach zur Landschaft.
Voilà, c'est vite. On a du vent.
- (Per Funk) Oui.
Sie sind mutig. Sie schwimmen dort.
Sieh dir das an! Auf einem Boot
muss man immer vorsichtig sein.
* Er lacht. *
Als kleiner Junge
waren die Schiffe für mich
der Inbegriff von Abenteuer.
Die Magie dieser Schiffe
hat mich angesprochen.
Als ich das zum ersten Mal
gesehen habe, sagte ich mir: Wow!
Ich fand sie so schön
und begann davon zu träumen,
auf einem solchen Schiff
zu arbeiten.
Valentinas Leidenschaft
gilt nicht nur ihrem Weinberg,
sondern auch ihrem Weinkeller.
Während der Lese
kann ich nicht einschlafen,
bevor ich nicht bei allen Fässern
war und alles gut ist.
Manchmal komme ich sehr spät,
Mitternacht, 2 Uhr morgens,
aber ich muss die Tour machen.
Sie sind wie Kinder.
Wenn du dich nicht um sie kümmerst,
bevor du ins Bett gehst,
kannst du nicht schlafen.
Von diesem Weisswein produziert
Valentina nur gerade 1'000 l.
Gelernt hat sie bei der Walliser
Weinikone Marie-Thérèse Chappaz.
Sie hat Valentina
vom biodynamischen Anbau überzeugt.
Ich habe es so gelernt
und möchte so natürlichen Wein
wie möglich produzieren,
ohne einzugreifen.
Wenn du gute Trauben im Keller
und gute Böden hast,
dann finde ich,
soll man die Erde machen lassen.
Es ist 13.30 Uhr.
Achtung, ich komme!
Beryl hat nur wenige Kinder
am Nachmittag.
Es bleibt Zeit,
ihnen ihre afrikanische Vergangenheit
ein bisschen näherzubringen.
Diese Ente ging reisen,
sie ging in die Ferien.
Sie ging in die Ferien in das Land,
in dem ich zur Welt gekommen bin,
nach Uganda, das ist in Afrika.
All die Fotos hier, auf denen das
Entchen irgendwo versteckt ist ...
Da ist sie.
- Ja, genau da ist es.
Darf Yuna wieder?
- Jetzt darf ich aber.
Hier ist es auch einfach.
Und hier bei dem?
Ich habe begonnen,
für mein Patenmädchen
solche Bücher über meine Reisen
zu machen.
In Uganda habe ich natürlich
auch eines gemacht.
Ich erzähle den Kindern
so viel davon, dann kommen Fragen:
"Warum bist du weiss,
wieso bist du in Afrika?"
"Ist es wirklich so, dass du
in Afrika geboren bist?" usw.
Ich drucke es einfach
einmal mehr für den Hort
und staune immer wieder,
wie viel Freude sie haben.
Aus ihrer Geschichte heraus
hat sie sich lange auch
in einer Schule in Nairobi engagiert.
Es gibt dann so Momente,
in denen man findet ...
Die Bilder, die von dort kommen,
wie die Kinder z.T.
1 Std. gehen müssen,
um in die Schule zu kommen.
Am Samstag und am Sonntag
möchten sie auch noch kommen.
Es fällt extrem viel weg,
wenn es diesen Tag nicht gibt,
und jeden Tag der gleiche Porridge
ist ein Highlight.
Beryl würde
das überzählige Essen aus dem Hort
gerne an Bedürftige im Quartier
verteilen, aber das darf sie nicht.
Der bürokratische Teil
in der Schweiz ...
Da gibt es immer wieder Dinge,
die schwer verständlich sind.
Man sieht, dass es
in anderen Ländern ganz anders läuft
und auch funktioniert.
Es nimmt den Menschen auch etwas
den Freiraum, etwas zu gestalten,
zu machen, weil überall immer
sehr viele Hindernisse da sind.
Z.T. machen sie Sinn,
z.T. werden sie aus meiner
Perspektive ad absurdum getrieben.
Kurt ist auf dem Weg
zur Berufsschule Olten,
um einen Schulbesuch bei
seinem Erstlehrjahrstift zu machen.
Er wollte nie weg von hier
und kennt die Gegend
wie seine eigene Hosentasche.
Ich gehe gerne in die Juraberge.
Gislifluh und Wasserfluh
sind so die Hausberge.
Das ist schon das,
was einen verbindet.
Ich war mit den Eltern
hier spazieren,
und selbst als Eltern ebenfalls.
Das ist schon etwas,
mit dem man verwurzelt ist.
Kurt nimmt seine Aufgabe
als Lehrmeister sehr ernst
und gibt ebenfalls Kurse hier.
40 Kaminfeger und Kaminfegerinnen
werden allein an
der Berufsschule Olten ausgebildet.
Gesamtschweizerisch sind es 192.
Es machen hier mal zwei auf.
Und das hier wegnehmen.
Der Deckel hält nicht.
Alex ist schon 2 Std. unterwegs.
Er macht
zwei bis drei Fahrten pro Tag
über den zweitgrössten See
Mitteleuropas.
So kommt er täglich
auch auf die französische Seite,
seine alte Heimat.
Was hält er als Franzose
von den Schweizern?
Die Schweizer sind sehr offen
für das, was im Ausland geschieht.
Aber ich glaube,
sie hängen auch sehr an ihrem Land.
So sehe ich es.
Sie würden ihr Land
um alles in der Welt verteidigen
und hängen sehr an ihren Traditionen
und an ihrer Heimat.
All die kleinen Sachen,
die die Schweiz ausmachen,
die darf man nicht antasten.
Die Genfer Schifffahrtsgesellschaft
transportierte 2017
fast 2,3 Mio. Passagiere,
und es werden jedes Jahr mehr.
Manche Passagiere nehmen sich Zeit,
stellen Fragen, machen Fotos usw.
Das ist Teil der Kreuzfahrt.
Beryl ist daran,
sich selbstständig zu machen.
In diesem Gebäude
bietet sie Coaching an.
Die drei Frauen
haben zusammen die Ausbildung gemacht
und treffen sich regelmässig
zum Feedback.
Beryl möchte sich auf einzelne Kinder
und ihre Eltern konzentrieren.
Ein Angebot, das es so bisher
ausserhalb von Schulen kaum gibt.
Es ist so, dass die Schulen vieles
anbieten, mehr im Abklärungsbereich:
Schulpsychologischer Dienst,
gewisse Therapieformen.
Gleichzeitig kann es aber für Eltern
auch wertvoll oder wichtig sein,
dass das eben nicht
in diesem Kontext passiert,
sondern dass sie selbst
etwas holen können,
was unabhängig vom Schulsystem
läuft.
Sie ist erst am Anfang,
könnte sich aber durchaus vorstellen,
ihr Konzept mit dem zu ergänzen,
was ihr selbst wichtig ist im Leben.
Es gibt noch
eine Vision im Hintergrund,
und das ist die Verbindung
der Leidenschaft für den Garten,
die Natur mit dem Coaching.
Immer wieder zu realisieren,
jetzt auch während der Ausbildung,
wie viel es einem geben kann,
wenn man in der Natur arbeiten kann
mit den Leuten.
* SBB-Zweiklang *
Valentina ist auf dem Weg
zu einer speziellen Weindegustation.
Sie produziert wenig,
aber teuren Wein.
Neben ihr gibt es rund 33'000
Weinproduzenten in der Schweiz.
Ca. 1 Mio. hl Wein
werden jährlich produziert.
Ist der Markt nicht schon gesättigt?
Ich glaube nicht,
dass er gesättigt ist.
Ich denke, wir müssen gute Weine
machen. Da ist Platz für alle.
Manchmal finde ich,
dass wir uns hier in der Schweiz
gegenseitig zu fest kritisieren.
Sowohl unter den Kantonen
als auch unter den Produzenten.
Es gibt doch Platz für alle.
Die Schweizer Rockband Gotthard
gibt ein Konzert in Lausanne.
Die Musiker haben Valentina
und den bekannten Tessiner Winzer
Sacha Pelossi beauftragt,
für sie einen neuen Wein zu kreieren.
Zusammengebracht hat sie Nicolas
Wüst, der Freund von Valentina.
Er ist Weinliebhaber
und Hansdampf in allen Gassen.
Salut. - Salut.
- Ça va? - Ça va.
- Comment ça va? - Magnifique.
Salut, Leo. - Salut.
C'est moi, magnifique? - Oui.
Die Bandmitglieder
haben eine Vorliebe für guten Wein
und treffen sich regelmässig.
Wir haben einen Weinclub im Tessin,
wir drei mit unseren Freunden.
Da sind Banker drunter, Gastronomen.
Wir machen immer
Abende mit Blinddegustationen,
wissen nicht, was dahintersteckt.
Wir haben die Themen,
und es gibt Gewinner.
Jeder bringt
seine beste Flasche mit.
Es ist schön: Es ist halb gesellig,
halb Weinliebe.
Drei verschiedene Varianten
mit unterschiedlichem Mischverhältnis
stehen zur Auswahl.
Leo Leoni, Nic Maeder
und Freddy Scherer
sind sich jedoch schnell einig.
Er ist ein bisschen fruchtiger,
runder.
Wenn wir noch ein Jahr warten,
kommt der zweite sicher gut.
Es ist 20 Uhr.
Alex versucht in der Vorsaison
möglichst früh nach Hause zu kommen.
Seine Familie und sein Zuhause
sind ihm das Wichtigste.
Hello!
Wenn ich nach Hause komme
und er mich hört,
dann wartet er schon auf mich,
der kleine Kerl.
Wenn ich nicht zu spät bin, reicht
es noch, um zusammen zu essen.
Das geniesse ich sehr.
Denn im Sommer, in der Hochsaison,
wird das nicht mehr möglich sein.
Im Sommer
sehen wir uns viel weniger.
Manchmal kommt es vor,
dass ich den Kleinen
eine ganze Woche nicht sehe,
weil er schon im Bett ist.
20.30 Uhr bei Beryl zu Hause.
Sie ist angekommen,
auch im übertragenden Sinne.
Es ist noch lustig:
Früher ging ich oft reisen
und hatte immer das Reissen,
wieder zu gehen.
Seit ich das hier habe,
ist ein neuer Aspekt dazugekommen.
Denn ich merke:
Das Schönste ist eigentlich,
wenn du ein Stück des Reisens
jeden Tag holen kannst.
In der Hängematte liegen
und in die Landschaft schauen
ist so ein Moment.
Ich merke: Das ist eine Qualität,
die ich jetzt auch hier habe.
So gesehen
ist schon die Schweiz mein Zuhause,
immer mehr auch geworden.
Vor drei Jahren konnten sie und ihr
Freund dieses Haus mit Garten mieten.
Philipp ist Lehrer, aber die beiden
verbindet nicht nur Berufliches,
sondern auch die Liebe zur Natur.
(Lachend) Hier wohnen
Franz und Rucola, zwei Goldfische.
Mein Patenkind und ihre Schwester
gaben die Namen.
Der rote ist Rucola
und der gelbe ist Franz.
Seit 15 Std. ist Kurt Fischer heute
schon unterwegs.
Aber für ihn
ist immer noch nicht Feierabend.
Seit Jahren engagiert er sich im
Vorstand des lokalen Gewerbevereins.
Der Austritt
aus dem Aargauischen Gewerbeverband
ist ja vom Tisch, oder?
Oder ist der nicht vom Tisch?
Doch! Das war ja einfach
ein Diskussionspunkt.
Man wollte einfach wissen,
was uns der Verband bringt.
Man hat gesagt, dass man nun
auf diese GV jemanden einlädt,
der erzählt, was sie tun.
- Und der kommt?
Der kommt, Otto Meier
hat da einen an der Angel.
Die Vorstandsmitglieder
sind alte Freunde.
Kurt findet es wichtig,
dass man sich freiwillig engagiert.
Da machst du einfach mit.
Wenn du in einem Dorf
einen Gewerbezweig betreibst,
habe ich das Gefühl,
dann machst du einfach mit.
Das ist Service public.
Ja, wie die Räbenlichter auch.
Wie der Räbenlichterumzug.
Der rechnet sich auch nicht,
und doch schenken wir jedes Jahr
am Räbenlichterumzug Glühwein aus.
Wie Lehrlingsausbildung:
Das rechnet sich nie.
Und doch machen wir es immer wieder,
weil es unsere Zukunft ist.
Und untereinander organisieren ist
irgendwie eben auch eine Zukunft.
Die Traktanden
sind schnell abgearbeitet -
Zeit für den gemütlichen Teil
des Abends.
Hoi!
Kurts Freundin Regula stösst dazu.
Die beiden
sind seit elf Jahren ein Paar.
Hoi!
- Hoi!
Schau jetzt!
Ein Plättchen in einer kleinen Runde
von Freunden kommt immer gut an.
280 km entfernt:
In Montherod ist es Zeit fürs Bett.
* Alex lacht. *
* Er kichert. *
Alex und Silvie machen auch das
gemeinsam. Sie sind ein gutes Team.
In meinem Leben
werde ich meine Frau nicht wechseln,
und ich werde auch
meinen Job nicht wechseln.
Ich realisiere langsam,
dass ich mir auch wieder mehr Zeit
für mich selbst nehmen kann.
Im Grossen und Ganzen habe ich also
einen Job, der mir gefällt.
Ich habe eine Familie,
mit der ich glücklich bin.
Es geht mir gut.
Und ich habe
meine kleinen Aktivitäten.
Das alles zusammen
gibt ein gutes Gleichgewicht.
Ich liebe das Leben, das ich habe.
Ich würde nichts ändern.
Im Metropole in Lausanne hat
das Konzert von Gotthard begonnen.
Bonsoir!
* Jubel *
Valentina und Nicolas
sind seit einem Jahr zusammen.
Zwei, die ihre Leidenschaft leben,
haben sich gefunden.
Ich habe nicht viel Zeit
und Nicolas arbeitet auch viel.
Dass er
einen dichten Terminplan hat, passt.
Ich könnte nicht
mit jemandem zusammen sein,
der bis 17 Uhr im Büro arbeitet.
Ich wäre dann auch gezwungen,
ein normales Leben zu führen.
* Sanfte Rockballade:
"Miss Me" von Gotthard *
# I wish you would burn, burn for me.
# I want you to miss me,
# I want you to beg, and even
write 25 letters you'll never send.
Für Kurt war es ein langer Tag.
Hoi zusammen.
Vor sieben Jahren haben Regula und er
das Haus in Veltheim gekauft.
Die Unfallchirurgin
und der Kaminfeger
haben sich in einer Klinik
in Aarau kennen- und lieben gelernt.
Es war ein Unfall.
* Beide lachen. *
Du sagst immer,
du seist mir vor die Füsse gerollt.
Ja, das war ja quasi so.
Ich war mit dem Betrieb Skifahren,
mit zwei Kaminfegergeschäften.
Ich als grosser Busfahrer.
Ich sagte, es solle sich ja niemand
trauen, einen Unfall zu machen.
Und schliesslich rollte ich dann
Regula horizontal vor die Füsse.
Ja, so haben wir uns kennengelernt.
Am Anfang fand ich, das gehe
gar nicht, Patient und Arzt.
Geht gar nicht. Aber wir haben dann
etwas anderes daraus gemacht.
Und geht gar nicht - geht sehr gut.
Du warst ja dann auch mal
nicht mehr Patient. - Ja, gut.
Willst du noch eine Kugel?
Eine kalte oder eine warme?
Auch Beryl und Philipp
haben es sich gemütlich eingerichtet.
Eine Sache gibt's jedoch,
die sie bedrückt:
Sie wünschen sich
schon lange ein Kind,
aber bisher
hat's noch nicht geklappt.
Es wäre übertrieben, zu sagen,
dass wir nicht auch hadern
und dass das nicht auch
immer wieder eine Belastung ist
für unsere Beziehung.
Dass da auch viel Verzweiflung,
Wut, Trauer und Frust ...
Das ist alles auch da.
Und doch sind wir an einem Punkt ...
Also ...
Es ist noch nicht klar, wie weiter,
wir haben aber immer noch Hoffnung.
Ich wollte eigentlich
mein Leben lang immer Kinder.
Und habe mir immer gesagt:
Wenn es klappt, ist es ein Geschenk
und dann ist das schön.
Und wenn es halt nicht geht,
dann ist etwas anderes bestimmt.
Und von daher, ja, ...
... schauen wir weiter.
Auf jeden Fall weiss ich, dass ich
mit dir an viele Orte mitkomme.
Und von daher freue ich mich
auf die Zukunft, die noch kommt.
Mit dir.
Ein Tag im Leben der Schweiz
geht zu Ende.
Valentina und Nicolas
sind auf dem Heimweg.
Morgen stehen sie wieder auf.
Und mit ihnen mehr als 8 Mio.
andere Menschen in der Schweiz.
Jeder mit seinem Alltag
und mit seiner Geschichte.
Nächste Woche: Cla Duri Blanke
fällt Bäume im Engadin.
Rita Streuli kontrolliert Billette
bei den Zürcher Verkehrsbetrieben.
Hansjörg Schwizer
markiert Signalisationen
auf Appenzells Strassen.
und Sabina Fehr
führt einen Zoo im Tessin.